you can stop being a cat now um the cat
will join us should we do little tour we
do a little tour of the of the set we're
gonna rock this is Christ it's
terrifying yeah we're done here on the
lobby said almost recording some videos
make sure I put this on probably not
sure if they can hear me roar you guys
can just stay there yeah cuz you're
tethered because we only have one
wireless mic so you can just I'll kick
out here do the little tour auntie
bellman it's got a steady calm in the
background what's going on yeah we're
ripping this bad boy off actually first
of all I'm the turn the hell around
because this is the old set this is the
million-dollar weight is Warren quite
he's sawing it word dawg we're in a
coffee or hating buddy hey oh gee game
for I remember watching you on old on
the spot when Rich was hosting in your
name and the credits yeah yeah we ran
yeah which was yeah exactly yes which is
of course over on the main set yeah you
did you design you built our I did with
the help of Mary and now and everybody
yeah yeah the old set try to put it
together yeah maybe give us a hand with
the new one as well maybe downstairs I'd
were you part of when they built this
one yeah as well this thing cost a
million bucks I hurt at least a Gleason
so these things apparently are like it's
the squares or so that the computer can
track the sort of this evening the
motion yeah because it was Chris used to
host here on a desk but it was like a
digital yeah set which is pretty crazy
virtual set yeah so they kept the wall
up but we haven't used not my time
anyway this is where we record obviously
a bunch of the old and GameSpot plays
and Mary doing her crazy horror streams
and whatnot and then this thing over
here this bad boy how long does this pin
here that Mary just like it's like two
years maybe I think the boys are sitting
there this is a I'm not sure can we even
see behind this then we kind of take a
Dan now because we're doing one more
video on it is the best thing on the set
by the way kingpin life of crime I think
this is don mo Horrocks poster
select the dumbest thing ever doesn't
have anything to do with the game I
behind this wall actually can we
actually go around shake we go ahead
this all fake it's all fake just what no
we can't kick it were doing one more
video it Anthony remote Roman built this
yes Anthony build whose are the duty
does all the brilliance and thumbnails
and graphics on gamespot he built this
we put all this dumb stuff in here we've
got some hot big rigs over the road
racing here of course oh really the ryan
i wanna didn't work out this is all just
free Tash we get especially like this
weird see-through [ __ ] big boss I
think that is I looks like snake eater I
know yeah I don't know maybe it's that
maybe it's five did Big Boss have an eye
patch and snake eater did he have his
eye he didn't all right that's probably
five Dovahkiin the world's worst fallout
thing fifty bucks feels like it we have
to pick all these games for for what we
wanted two to go here so it's actually
pretty good collection of games these
are all empty we have them all the
library and I'm not sure if we're
keeping any of these actually an xbox
with some xbox one stuff in here that's
PSP games we got we actually think we
made a point of getting all like 10 to
10 at attends games bonded over the year
in here tony hawk pro skater 3 is here
half-life 2 is there i didn't get 10 it
and I got 9.6 thing World of Warcraft's
here in the tenets of town on gamespot
all those hot swat4 andi baman knows
it's a hot video game need to play yeah
it was about Kane and Lynch I thinking
here as well all those hot references yo
she's here this thing never really came
together the way we wanted to do the
heads cuz predator was put on and I was
like he's not really video game thing
but yeah what are you a bad idea we
never took down and we got this is I
keep forgetting he's here and it wasn't
until we got the vault boy one that I
was like oh yeah Bethesda like has this
ridiculous budget of sending massive
statues to like everyone and every year
game spawn or gamestop in the country i
did it god damn it and then the last one
Warren you did this this is your work
no not your signature the signature
we'll all of the game developers on
internet peoples and something's already
falling apart the whole buildings going
Vince Zampella so this if you want to
steal anyone's identity for any
developers that's Vincent powers at
peter molyneux is here we got Nathan
valla who apparently is a garbage gamer
I don't know who wrote that Eric Pope I
think did bless you Mary gay kill her
the il-2 sturmovik guys decided to this
is what they did this when it was like
no names on it at all they just decide
the right hardcore with passion across
the whole thing and yeah some great
stuff here alex g bailey keithley yes of
course hashtag sick laughs what Sean
Sean McKenna's when he left yeah when he
went up the Seattle we let them write
something and of course he painted the
wall Theresa derringer i think has done
the best one here for canon broadlands
pretty good Greg Miller of course our
friend of the site CounterSpy I am bread
and who Combofiend Combofiend they're up
there I love DP John carnage hoot which
john van yucky voted there sid meier
just just hanging out there with mike
bithell all those great ones off my
cutlets here we go there's that og
what's a let's gamespot old [ __ ] where'd
you find that I remember that big noise
you heard just a second ago yeah that
was me getting it from the other side of
this wall is there any of that old stuff
still there yeah there's like oh we
should i do not want to arrange you guys
got but like because this used to be
there's to be this curving wall there
was a set of on the spot is it still
behind there yeah okay c'mon is that
it's kick that we can't kick doll there
we got one more video who's there you
guys having fun yeah yeah yeah I think
it has mosses up from a call of duty
stream we did all this [ __ ] this is the
same this is Albert oh yeah you guys
never get to see this is the production
you what's up so Eric take increase your
range oh really yeah they want you to be
able to go
I think we're come over come over come
over well we got back here here's this
the wall oh yeah look at this we might
need some lights back here we got me so
I think you make make it here hey he's
gots like it's got this on it now cuz we
they sometimes get these like d calls or
whatever and like paint over the top of
us up now huh we're doing our last tour
of the old set and was this what this
was this is the bottom line thing also
wasn't call of duty yeah so this is the
old set this is the old on this bomb
we're just hanging out in the back yeah
what are these things Jesus Christ
there's so much stuff here yeah yeah so
it's all getting torn down I'll take any
of this stuff oh yeah is raya can you
see any of their logos banking oh my god
yo games doc I used to be like a window
like a fake window type thing all right
this is see-through good light it back
video games com right there and this
awful summer I think Don the whoring gun
person who's worked here longer than 540
club shirt as well how long you been
working here nine and a half years the
thankless job laughs setups lost about
the Hank yeah that's me yeah graphic
sick dad uh yeah you were working when
this was when this ends but it was new
when I really just came in New this
whole sent lights up on the bottom fell
plugs in we were used to replace all of
these banners we had tournament TV oh
yeah we had one my shame button mashing
both one and two we had today on the
spot we had gamespot sink on the spot
again yeah we had gamescom she does this
the only thing that has video games at
home this is the only one and all this
is getting tossed um giving this life
ended up in your bathroom
good I mean yeah sure bring on set
what's this what is this that's Brian
Ekberg hat oh is it really hurt in the
rafters when you stop truth ah oh no
what you just pull it down yeah oh yeah
it smells like you're still in the
rafters shout out to Brian Ekberg will
see a fourth sub motorsport six oh my
god Ben Ben's leaving with the only look
this is a leftover from e3 2008 down in
Santa Monica oh gods yeah yeah yeah the
weird one that was on the boardwalk when
they tried to dance I xiii yeah this has
been in my office it was ingesting
Calvert's office yeah and that was in my
office and now it's going to whoever
wants it i'll figure out yeah hashtag
you came spot surfboard let us not how
much luck do we have 40 is Alma here is
Alma here use peaches by the way just so
people don't talk when we're straight
when we're actually broadcasting we have
Alma am here what's your surname again
fettle paxton petals mother don't a
mother not daughter and in in fear first
encounter assault recon and yeah so
that's we put Alma there so nobody
nobody [ __ ] with us what you what you
got we got oh can I can I drag it over
just logo bar so double-click the psyche
you're done yeah you speak softly good
no I got no more chords all right let's
go back in let's go back in come on
everybody I wonder if my computer is
still hanging out back here yeah you
there you guys are such good dudes just
no you're not oh you are here I love you
sorry I should have moved that Swedes
wadded what a video game adventure what
else is here look at this oh Jesus
oh my god I have never seen right all
right I guess that's a that's it for
live shows from here the third floor on
a CBS is building the time trotters room
we also didn't get to see that somewhere
else and we didn't get to say hi to
everyone who was in the who's working
hard at the moment we've got all that
game of yourself happening this week you
crazy kids and we're almost done we've
got one more video to shoot here after
the show we're going to get a bunch of
the report cards for various consoles up
on the site in the next coming days but
yeah from everyone here for who's new
faces and old faces and middle faces and
firing faces and faces you don't get to
see which is Mary in the background who
there's so much work to do this show
every single week like this job and Josh
where's Josh go see Josh go away with
josh Josh [ __ ] do anything he's
probably pay rocket League let's do it
there he is Josh Shaw master director do
some what do some hot directing yeah
joshie you can't hear Josh but what he
wants you to know is destiny sucks and
rocket League is the best game of the
year gave it here you can do it all
right that's to show everyone thanks so
much for everyone who's been watching
and gave spot here in the third floor
will be back in twenty sixteen with more
hot live video game coverage on a new
floor and a new set so until then stick
around for all I gave me to your stuff
and we will see you yeah there I got a
sick transition did he go we almost
don't fake the black all right we'll see
you in 2016